I would like to propose a toast it's
really great to see it I wish it wasn't
just the dark times that brought us
together the man you're looking for is
Vandal Savage who is an immortal this is
a cycle that has played out to the last
four thousand years we're chasing down
an immortal madman on a rampage against
a reincarnated Warrior Priestess our
life suddenly becomes Indiana Jones
twisters I grew up in Wisconsin those
are memories come back to you so what
other things as well Savage is going to
decimate such a city what we need to do
is get rid of him you're not gonna get
rid of him watch us
everything either is willing to die to
protect us it's what makes them all
heiress
well fine
hey youtubers is Charlie so there's some
new flair footage that confirms the the
big crossover episode is gonna deal with
hawkman and hawkgirl origin story and it
looks like it's binding Vandal Savage to
them it just it confirms some of that
but we also may have gotten some
information about the legends of
tomorrow premiere in a separate talk
that Greg Berlanti like that you know
the Overlord producer of everything was
doing recently so I'll talk about that
after I talk about Flair oh stuff so
Vandal Savage in the clip says my hate
will follow you across all eternity then
we see a giant meteor that looks like
it's crashing into an Egyptian temple so
I think what this is is it just confirms
that they're combining vandal savage's
origin story how he got struck by the
meteor with Hawkman and Hawkgirl
now vandal savage's original backstory
put him somewhere near Neanderthals the
meteor that struck him and made him
immortal also evolved his mind so he's
kind of like a throwback to crow Magnum
Hawkman and Hawkgirl were originally
normal Egyptians Carter Hall was
originally named Prince Khufu and he had
this rival priest called hat set set
ends up killing Khufu and his lover
shayera with an nth metal dagger and
that's what starts the curse of
reincarnation so what I'm wondering is
is if in this trailer that meteor is
made of enth metal or some similar
mineral that starts the cycle of death
and rebirth now one of the side effects
of this reincarnation cycle if you
haven't read the comics is that when
Hawkman and Hawkgirl die they get
reincarnated obviously but when they're
reincarnated they don't remember their
previous lives so they also don't
remember they used to be lovers they
usually they don't get reincarnated
right next to each other they have to
find each other and part of their
tragedy is is that they usually only
find each other and remember their past
lives right before they get ready to die
again so you know they they find each
other they fall in love again they
remember everything and then one of them
usually dies I don't know if they're
gonna do that again on the TV show like
I don't think they're gonna immediately
kill Hawkman off because he's gonna be
on legends of tomorrow so at least I'll
be 13 episodes but I'm expecting that at
some point they will address that as it
stands right now it looks like Hawkgirl
probably died recently because she has
no memory of her previous life that's
why in the trailer you hear Hawkman
saying you're starting to remember he
brings her her armor one fun Easter Egg
is that at a certain point in the comics
they had a child together
Hector Hall that went on to become one
of the doctor fates but because there's
a bunch of different versions of hawkman
and hawkgirl in the comics in case
you're confused
this is JSA backstory the most recent
retcon of their history because part one
of the episode is called legends of
yesterday I think that's when we'll get
this flashback and they'll explain the
actual origins so it seems like they're
being fairly true to the comics they're
just marrying a couple aspects of vandal
savage's origin story and tying it to
Hawkman and Hawkgirl roles origin so I'm
actually kind of wondering if they're
tying Vandal Savage to Hawkman and
Hawkgirl if they've erased a mortal man
from continuity and they're giving
aspects of that character to Hawkman and
Hawkgirl the the thing about a mortal
man if you're not familiar with that
character is he's like vandal savage's
so Lavar like Gorilla Grodd has an
ultimate nemesis in the comics called so
Lavar like an equally smart gorilla
that's good instead of being evil like
Grodd a mortal man is like the other
side of the coin from Vandal Savage
he got his powers from the same meteor
that Vandal Savage got his powers from
so at least until they explained it I'm
just gonna think of Hawkman Hawkgirl is
like the new immortal man of the DC
Universe even though even though
technically their origin is closer to
their actual origin story from the
comics being reincarnated isn't quite
the same thing as being immortal being
immortal means being free from death in
order to being reincarnated you have to
die first
so because Merlyn calls Vandal Savage
immortal maybe if he gets struck by this
meteor and ends up having a different
effect on him than it has on Hawkman and
Hawkgirl I am really hoping that ends up
being an infidel meteorite that would be
so badass but moving on to legends of
tomorrow Greg Berlanti just did this big
interview with the Paley Center where he
said that they hope to drop legends of
tomorrow episode 1 on January 21st
that's actually a Thursday which makes
sense you have flash on Tuesday arrow on
Wednesday and then you'd have legends of
tomorrow on Thursday so legends will
follow those other two shows and yes all
the characters will crossover even the
villains will crossover with legends of
tomorrow but once it's all said and done
you can think of it as almost like a
Netflix series the way they've weaved
the story together that's why they've
shortened the run so they can serialize
it a little bit more and it'll be more
binge-watch friendly at the end but he
also said some other really cool stuff
about the DC Universe in general
especially like the TV shows so I'm just
gonna play this clip here if this is
Greg Berlanti
for those of you who don't know Gregg is
currently shepherding the numbers 1 & 2
highest-rated new series of the year
with a third series the legends of
tomorrow that we have very high hopes
for on January the 21st so from our
perspective again thanks to my friend
and protege we're having a very good
year III came back to Warner's as he
said and you know I had participated in
a film called Green Lantern which wasn't
the best it wasn't really sort of what I
had seen and written in my head it was
kind of taken from us and somebody
everybody else sort of did something
very different with it and and but I
came back and Peter in spite of that
said why don't you do a DC show and he's
probably the most convincing man in
Hollywood and I said well you know if I
were to do one the one that would
interest me the most was his arrow in
part because there's a way to do there's
a reason to do that show at the time you
know I really felt like there was a
reason to do it on television and that
his origin story could happen
concurrently with the rest of the show
and you know in a film you'd get the
origin story done in 20 minutes and
you'd be on - you know they're sort of
the hero but here we could sort of tell
them simultaneously and and so that was
sort of the initial kind of impulse for
it
so what's gonna happen next is as heroes
and villains fan fest is coming up if
they do anything noteworthy or drop new
footage I will totally do a video for it
I'm sure they'll be talking a lot about
legends of tomorrow so it'll be a lot of
fun but I will say congratulations to
last week's reverse-flash giveaway
winner Lord minecraft be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info I'm gonna
try and do a new Supergirl video this
week but because there's so much Jessica
Jones that I have to get through that
just that might be delayed till next
week why guys wait for everything to
post you can click here for my first
Jessica Jones episode video it's so so
badass make sure you guys watch that
series and you can click here for all my
other flash arrow videos from this week
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight